America we need to talk we've Grown
Apart these last few years it's not you
it's Mississippi it's Mississippi PE
research reports that over the past 7
years Americans have increasingly felt
that their political opposites are
stupider more dishonest more immoral and
lazier and the simple fact is they're
right regardless of what side they're on
I'm playing both sides so that I always
come out on top and in light of this
increasing political acrimony among
Americans some have begun to think it
was good well it lasted but it's time to
call it quits on this whole Union thing
for example Texas governor Greg Abbott
has declared a crisis at the border and
says that Texas has a right to
self-defense and is going to take over
immigration duties from the US
government and stop the US government
from interfering and many politicians
agree like Republican representative
margerie Taylor green who triggered a
firestorm of criticism by repeatedly
demanding a national divorce in which
red America and blue America go their
separate ways and we should listen to
Congress person green because she knows
from experience what it means when
someone decides they can't stand you
anymore and unceremoniously leaves you
but while green was pillared on all
sides for her call for splitting up the
union a March 2023 poll suggests that
around 1th of the population or 66
million Americans if you can extrapolate
from that are amendable to a national
divorce looks like the 250e itch is real
and even soon to be also Rand Nikki
Haley is on tape claiming the
Constitution allows states to secede do
you believe the states of the United
States have the right to suive I think
that they do I mean the Constitution
says that and admittedly these numbers
are alarming though it's unclear to what
extent it reflects a sincere desire to
break up the Union as opposed to a way
to register their displeasure that the
person you didn't vote for became
president uh but in 2009 governor of
Texas and king of failing upwards Rick
Perry jokingly suggested his state would
consider secession after the election of
Barack Obama but this isn't just a red
State thing in 2017 a poll found at 32%
of California voters supported seceding
from the US following the election of
Donald Trump up from 20% in 2014 and
again and after Joe Biden was elected
Texas is once again partying like it's
1861 by refusing to accept election
results in threatening secession
regardless what was once Unthinkable the
breakup of the United States has become
a real issue we can no longer treat as a
mayor
hypothetical that
doesn't South America take it away so
today legal iglet let's talk about what
would happen if States opted to formally
leave the union and whether that's
legally possible now typically it's
mistake to treat cranks with any kind of
serious inquiry after all margerie
Taylor green is not exactly what one
would call a constitutional scholar but
her proposal is not without precedent
after all the United States of America
was born out of secession and ever since
the colonists declared themselves an
independent nation threats to leave the
union have long been made by various
constituents of the US but rarely acted
on and in fact the first serious threat
of secession came not from the Deep
South but from New England in 1814 New
England delegates tended the Hartford
Convention to protest President James
Madison's merant policies and the War of
1812 with more extreme delegates making
an unsuccessful push to leave the union
and then and stop me if you've heard
this one already after the election of
Abraham Lincoln in 1860 11 Southern US
states broke off from the Republic to
form the Confederate States of America
triggering a bloody 4-year Civil War and
of course despite modern attempts by
some to claim the Confederacy was
fighting for states rights not slavery
we know that that's pretty much false
how do we know well for one the majority
of the states explicitly wrote in their
Declarations of succession that the
reason they seceded was to preserve
slavery and prevent political equality
between whites and blacks but you know
sometimes people are only textualist
when it's convenient but even cities
have gotten on the secession bandwagon
or in this case perhaps the secession
yacht Martha's Vineyard along with
Nantucket actually voted to secede for
Massachusetts yes in 1977 the Martha
Vineyard Selectmen voted 10 to2 for
secession to protest a redistricting
plan that would reduce their
representation in the state legislature
uh on an even smaller level some
Americans have simply proclaimed their
property to be an independent micro
nation for example in 1998 Kevin B
declared his 11.3 acre property in the
Nevada desert to be the Republic of
mosia and since 1998 president ba has
ruled his micronation as a benevolent
dictator I am president Kevin B of the
Republic of massia a tiny self- declared
country within Nevada that's within the
United States we have everything that a
nation should have
Bank stamps and H office to date no
country has recognized the legitimacy of
this micronation whose currency is tied
to the price of cookie dough now
obviously if you're going to try and
succeed from the union you're going to
need a good lawyer but if you want a
great lawyer my firm the eagle team can
help if you've suffered data breach
especially if you've gotten a data
breach letter or were involved in a car
crash or have dealt with sexual
harassment we can represent you or help
find you the right attorney who can it's
so important to talk to a lawyer right
away so you can get the best
representation and find out all of what
your options are just click on the link
in the description for free consultation
with my team because you don't just need
a legal team you need the eagle team
click on the link below so let's jump
right into it does the Constitution
provide a right to unilaterally secede
from the union well to give everyone's
favorite answer it depend no actually no
uh States and localities have zero
constitutional right to declare
themselves independent and break away
from the United States any votes to
suceed unilaterally is just political
virtue signaling and uh with zero legal
effect and yet the quote constitutional
right to secede is a myth that refuses
to die but for really inter interesting
reasons now no state has bought into
this mythical right to secede more than
the Lone Star State in fact Texans love
to repeat the legend that Texas as a
condition to joining the US negotiated
an annexation treaty which grants them
the unique right to unilaterally secede
from the union and once again become the
Republic of Texas but you might be
surprised to learn that the terms of the
Texas annexation contain no such
provision but Texas won't be cowed by
your big city fact checking and literacy
uh you know as a result the states
conservative leaders continue to falsely
proclaim a right to succeed in June of
2022 Texas Republicans were once again
Whistling Dixie by adding to its party
platform that Texas retains the right to
secede from the United States declaring
a right to nullify the federal laws they
don't like under the 10th Amendment and
urging the Texas legislature to pass a
referendum to determine whether or not
the state of Texas should reassert its
status as an independent nation and in
March of 2023 Texas State representative
Brian Slayton introduced a bill to put
said referendum on the November 2023
ballot and just in time for the 2024
election the Texas Supreme Court
declined to take up a case from a
conservative group that wanted to add
Texas secession to this year's
presidential primary ballot but that
raises the question on what legal
grounds do some Texans claim the state
has a right to seced well according to
Daniel Miller the president of the pro-
secession Texas nationalist movement
Texas has an implied right to secede
because the Constitution doesn't say it
can't Article 1 Section 10 of the US
Constitution lists everything states are
forbidden from doing guess what's not in
there withdraw
in addition Miller claims that the 10th
Amendment which says that the federal
government only has power spelled out in
the Constitution or not delegated by the
states means that states can choose to
leave now this argument isn't completely
insane there is a Canon of construction
that allows you to interpret contracts
or statutes uh by what is included
specifically it's based on the Latin
phrase is em generous which means the
company it keeps if you create a list of
things and something is not included in
that list then you can assume that it
was not meant to be included in that
list that being said the argument is
also similar to the one used in the
movie airbud uh basically there's
nothing in the Constitution that says
you can't secede from the United States
or that a dog can't play basketball but
won't find anything in there says a dog
can't play he's right ain't no rule said
the dog can't play basketball so I
wouldn't necessarily hang my hat on that
argument most likely airbud would be
able to secede before Texas especially
because legal Scholars and
constitutional experts seem to
overwhelmingly agree that the US con
stitution does not allow for secession
for example Stanford Levon who is a law
professor at University of Texas Austin
said that quote almost no lawyer would
take that argument seriously I do
believe it is viewed as a closed
question and courts that have weighed in
on the issues of secession have always
shot them down in 2010 Alaska's Supreme
Court ruled that secession was illegal
and thus an initiative putting the
question to a vote could not be placed
on the ballot so any effort to put a
matter on the ballot in Texas would
likely not be constitutional either even
the late Supreme Court Justice and
Scalia who followed a strict form of
constitutional interpretation dubbed
originalism said that there's no legal
basis for secession and we learned
scalia's views on this matter in a quite
unusual way back in 2006 legally minded
screenwriter Daniel turkowitz wrote a
letter to all nine Supreme Court
Justices for advice on a farsal script
he was writing in which Maine secedes
from the US and joins Canada leading to
a climactic showdown at the Supreme
Court Scalia was the only Justice to
provide a substantive response to
turkowitz and the late Justice was
unequivocal quote to begin with the
answer is clear if there was any
constitutional issue resolved by the
Civil War it is that there is no right
to secede hence in the Pledge of
Allegiance One Nation indivisible the
Justice also explained why a secession
case would never end up before The
Supreme Court quote I find it difficult
to Envision who the parties to this
lawsuit might be is the state suing the
United States for a declaratory judgment
but the United States cannot be sued
without its consent and it has not
consented to this sort of suit I am sure
that poetic license can overcome all
that but you do not need legal advice
for that good luck with your screenplay
and although the Supreme Court has never
heard a direct secession case it did
address the question indirectly in 1869
and once again it involves Texas the
Supreme Court case of Texas versus white
centered on the crap State selling US
Treasury bonds to help Finance its war
with the Union a brokerage firm
purchased some of these bonds and then
resold them to investors and after the
South's defeat the union supported
reconstruction government of Texas filed
suit against the brokerage firm directly
with the Supreme Court as the con ition
confers original jurisdiction to the top
court for cases in which a state is a
party and Texas argued that the rebel
government had illegally sold these
bonds and the state was therefore
entitled for their return Andor
repayment the brokerage firm argued that
these sales were legal and it had no
duty to repay Texas and in a 5 to3
ruling the Supreme Court ruled that the
Confederate State's sale was illegal
because Texas's succession itself was
illegal and as a matter of law it never
happened writing for the majority of the
Court chief justice in secret grizzly
bear Sam and Chase who once famously
graced the f of the now defunct $110,000
Bill declared quote uh the union between
Texas and the other states was as
complete as perpetual and as indisoluble
as the union between the original states
there was no place for reconsideration
or revocation except through Revolution
or through the consent of the states so
the Supreme Court has spoken there are
only two paths to secession Revolution
or a consensual disillusion now before
you go thinking that declaring war
against the United States is just this
one weird trick that allows you to
secede or uh
governments hate it because it's so
successful I should note that Waging War
against the government is not legal is
what we lawyer types would call treason
a crime that is punishable by death #
not legal advice don't commit treason uh
also seceding by force uh even
unsuccessfully or especially
unsuccessfully will typically result in
a high body count and during the Civil
War about 620,000 people or 2% of the
nation's total population were killed so
unless you're jazzing to murder uh
thousands if not millions of your
friends and neighbors uh spend decades
in prison for sedition or get executed
for treason Revolution is probably not
the ideal secession path In fairness
that would be the most Texas thing that
you could do Tex will never do
that but there is one way to succeed
without murdering a whole bunch of
people the states and the federal
government consent to your sucession now
of course some states already act like
their own independent nations and have
the wealth to back that up uh if
California and Texas were their own
countries they would be the fifth and
10th largest economies in the world by
GDP respectively and if one state leaves
it's easy to imagine the domino effect
of mass Exodus of red Andor blue States
so what would a consensual breakup
between one or more States look like
well in a December 2022 article for the
new Republic Bren tanah Hill a former
Naval aviator and a senior defense
analyst gamed out what a divided United
States of America might actually look
like in the piece tanah Hill who
outlined scenarios for what she referred
to as a soft secession and hard
secession which he described as akin to
a separation versus a messy divorce
respectively in tanah Hill's view a soft
secession could look like the 56 Nation
British Commonwealth where Nations like
New Zealand Canada and Australia
technically owe allegiance to the crown
but in practice they are all their own
Sovereign Nations and the Monarch's role
is entirely ceremonial uh the US doesn't
have to swear allegiance to the crown
because we're dope and we do dope things
but she also cited as an example the
Kurds in Northern Iraq and that while
technically part of Iraq the Iraqi
government exercises little control and
the Kurds have their own armed forces
that cooperate in anti-terror operations
against Isis uh though that hasn't
exactly worked out especially well for
the Kurds historically but the idea of a
soft secession has its supporters on the
conservative albeit never Trump side of
the aisle like former National Review
columnist David French French argued
that different states and different
regions should be empowered to go about
American life in a radically different
way without Federal intervention so in
practice this would look like a beefed
up version of of federalism which French
describes as tolerance through
self-governance and Community autonomy
in the system more power would be
delegated to the states while the
federal government takes a hands-off
approach to let the Laboratories of
democracy chart their own paths So in
theory this type of soft secession would
have the benefit of preserving the union
and America's Global power in a troubled
World while leaving open the possibility
of reconciliation but that would also
require Americans tolerating policies
without a federal floor of Rights and or
protections that many would find
detestable and unacceptable including
dissenting citizens within said States
but tanah Hill argues that a hard
secession is a more dangerous
proposition quote this would involve a
clean break no more off sensible
allegiance to a government in Washington
simply regions breaking off and forming
their own countries based on common
culture religion ethnicity and Regional
identity according to tanhill a hard
secession could take many forms it could
be like the outcome of the fall of the
Soviet Union in 1991 which triggered an
economic collapse and a huge decrease in
life expectancy not to mention the
matter of nuclear materials being
scattered across successor States
tanah Hill also cites to the fall of
Yugoslavia in the 90s which resulted in
a decade of Civil War and genocide or
could be like Taiwan and China a decades
Long Cold armed standoff but apart from
the legality or illegality of the whole
situation a national divorce even a
consensual one would be an absolute
bureaucratic nightmare with a ton of
unanswered questions like how would the
national debt be divided what happens to
all the money paid into Federal programs
like Social Security and Medicare for
those leaving the US what do we do with
Federal assets like the gold Ford at
Fork KNX or the US military bases and
for that matter what happens to the US
military itself and the nukes uh dibs on
the nukes um yeah I'm sure this will
work out just fine in short yes
theoretically you could break up the
United States through mutual consent but
only a great personal economic and
political costs there just so many
complicated issues to resolve even with
a mutual separation not to mention that
America's standing in the world would
immediately and permanently be
diminished and even if the initial
separation were peaceful which I kind of
doubt uh there would be years of
disputes from trade and redrawing
borders and as history has shown
regarding boundary disputes uh there's
no guarantee that we wouldn't break out
into an allout bloody second Civil War
so I know we've all been fussing and
feuding but let's just take a breath and
remember as Americans we have more in
common than what divides us and find a
way to work through our issues together
at least until the kids go to college
and it looks like a frightening number
of states are going along with the plan
to give the middle finger to the federal
government that didn't work out so well
last time so margerie stop trying to
make secession happen it's not going to
happen instead let's just all take a
breath and remember as Americans we have
more in common than divides us and find
a way to work through our issues
together at least until the kids go to
college and if you're looking to send
your kids to college you'll probably
need to find ways to manage your
finances and save money luckily today
sponsor rocket money can help for
reasons that I don't understand mint is
shutting down and Rocket money is one of
my favorite mint Replacements to keep
track of all of my expenses and it's
better in so many ways now recently I
had a problem trying to get a handle on
all my subscriptions between my personal
and professional subscriptions I was
paying out almost $20,000 per year yes
being a real lawyer and also a YouTuber
turns out is extremely expensive now I
hadn't been paying too much attention to
what I was subscribed to and I couldn't
believe once I started to track all my
monthly expenses how much money was
going out in small amounts every month
but rocket money is an all-in-one
Finance platform that helps you save
more and spend less rocket money allows
you to manage subscriptions lower bills
build a custom budget and grow your
savings all in one place I'm using
rocket money to help me cancel all the
subscriptions I wasn't using for apps I
hadn't even watched shows on for months
that I no longer needed now that
succession and Game of Thrones are over
but rocket money alerts you of important
changes that impact your score and
offers you insights on ways to improve
it it told me that a service increased
their price by $100 per year I'll have
to take a look at that and their budget
setting feature is great too I can
automatically monitor my spending by
category get notifications when I've
exceeded my budgets and visualize my
spend to earn ratio by month quarter or
year plus rocket money can help you keep
track of your credit and net worth so
once you canceled all those old
subscriptions you can watch the line go
up it lets me keep track of my whole
financial picture including cash debts
Investments retirement accounts
collectible items and more rocket money
has helped save its customers an average
of $720 a year with over 500 million in
canceled subscriptions so to save more
and spend less join the over 5 million
members using rocket money today go to
Rocket money.com legal eagal or click on
the link in the description to get
started for free you can also unlock
even more features with premium again
just click on the link that's on screen
right now or down below to get started
for free and after that click on this
link over here for more legal or I'll
see you in court